all right Heidi Spencer we're here to
celebrate a hundred episodes of marriage
boot camp but I want to talk about a
different show the hills new beginning
season two we're filming it right now
right so people maybe I personally
haven't started filming yet their baby
cameras go we can't you know sir people
are being casted and not cast since I
know how it is in Hollywood yeah a lot
has happened since you finished filming
season one like this love quadrangle
started there was paint li there was
Miley Brody Josie what's going on that
happened before the end of season one
who knows right maybe it was going on
during you know a secretive you know
yeah it was it's amazing I love it all
as I was just telling Heidi on the way
here Cody Simpson season two up the
hills I think it's going down one of the
chances we get to see Miley on season
two I'm gonna just I'm not gonna
speculate but you know just say probably
not likely I do think she's obviously
Hill's fan though right she's watching
she's engaged friends with it dating
cast members sometimes allegedly we
don't know we're actually
why not all the puns his Kaitlyn's still
a part of this group are we going to see
Kaitlyn story unfold
whoo oh my gosh she did it I know we're
know I can't even say somebody fake nice
like yeah I tried hold on let me check
it with my crystals no I just oh yeah I
just I'm just going off the last episode
and she said in her Testament what I
don't care for those so that's just
resonating with me
so maybe if we had more time to get to
know each other we would've been really
good friends so maybe she'll be involved
okay
is Josie Canseco gonna be involved we
love Jose I actually did a show with
Josie a long time ago the
mother-daughter experiment so I lived
with Josie for two weeks so feel like I
know her pretty well
that's right yeah so yeah we've
manifesting that as well Kody Josie but
maybe not Caitlin at least not when
you're around
oh no I know I'm not anti anyone I'm
just saying I don't know where cuz what
she filled with Brody who would she feel
where that's yeah that's maybe there
still I don't know what's going on maybe
they still hang out totally missing out
on like there's Jade and I'm most
excited to actually see Aaron Carter in
person it's that kissed my cheek Wow did
any of the tattoo rub off on yours
okay inks dry the ink dried so yeah
that's that's exciting
Gunnar's growing up getting older we
think about baby number two
next few months I think we're gonna
start trying for baby to news to you ah
no it's just every time I hear that out
loud it's like oh my god here we go
it's gonna be such a journey I remember
you were it took a while to get you on
the train hanging off the caboose real
deal but we don't just starting to Sleep
Train so it's been a long two years for
Heidi no sleeves high-alert you pulled
out all the Punjab and rolled over The
Bachelor guys I think we're okay this is
just like The Surreal Life on we TV is
wild
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]